I have the privilege of having been
since we're all talking about our moms
of having been raised by actors and film
lovers and since early childhood my
mother brought me here to see foreign
films and they were truly I think the
greatest inspiration to why I wanted to
become an actor at a very young age so I
felt very privileged to get to be asked
to present the awards this evening for
excellence in filmmaking from schools
outside of the United States the Academy
working with select the International
Association of film and television
schools viewed 51 films from 29
different countries this year prior to
selecting tonight's winners this is the
32nd year that the Academy has honored
filmmakers from schools lokai located
outside of the United States and these
ceremonies and tonight we have three
films that our members have selected for
this year's accolades so let's begin
with our bronze medal winner made by
director el Mar Eamon off from the
international film school Cologne in
Germany the film the swing of the
coffin-maker tells a poignant story of
yahoo-hoo as the title would suggest
makes coffins
yogev lives a rather austere life along
with his mentally challenged son Musa
unfortunately Yago has fallen into a
pattern of cruelty both mentally and
physically toward his son until one day
when they received some devastating news
thank you to the Academy I'm sorry for
my my English it's not it's not so good
I wish it could be I want to thank to my
crew part of the crew is here thank you
especially to the producer
and to my biology teacher in the school
because I I wanted to study biology and
I go to I went to the teacher with a you
know subscribed biology thing paper and
certain hey biology and he said to me
don't do it
so I I didn't do it and first of all and
want to thank to my family thank you